last time we covered how you can use
google cloud platform metrics as service
level indicators
to measure the reliability of your
services and set reliability targets
using slos
but what do you do if you need custom
telemetry for your slis today
i'm going to show you how to use
prometheus and open senses to write
custom metrics
and define slis and slos using them
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
imagine a basic web application
architecture like this while we can use
the metrics emitted by the load balancer
to track things like request counts and
response latency
what if our application running on gk
needs to keep track of specific
transaction details
and write a custom counter for them what
if we want to use this kind of custom
telemetry as our sli for the service
this is where custom metrics come in
today i'm going to show you how to use
two open source approaches to custom
metric telemetry
the first one is prometheus prometheus
is an open source systems monitoring the
learning toolkit
originally built at soundcloud it has a
very active developer and user community
and joined the cloud native computing
foundation back in 2016.
this is the architecture prometheus uses
to collect metrics the general idea is
that your service needs to expose a
dedicated metrics endpoint
which prometheus will then scrape to
collect metric data that data is stored
in a time series database and can be
queried through a web ui or an api
we'll link to the full code sample in
the show notes let's have a look at how
to instrument an application written in
node.js
to emit counter and histogram metrics
start by defining the metrics themselves
for each specify the metric type its
name and help message that will describe
what the metric is capturing
to track latency use a histogram and
call its observe method
to increment counters call their ink
method finally
create a dedicated metrics endpoint in
your application that prometheus will
use to scrape for metrics
the instrumentation is done now if you
go to the slash metrics endpoint in your
app
you'll see a page that looks like this
the metrics and their values are written
out here
now you need to configure prometheus
itself to scrape this endpoint
you do that by adding some annotations
in the deployment spec in your
application
enable scraping and define the port and
end point where the metrics are
available
next you need to ingest these metrics
into cloud monitoring
we'll link the detailed instructions in
the show notes but the basic idea is
that you patch your prometheus server
with a collector
that will send these metrics to cloud
monitoring once your metrics are
available there
you're ready to use them for slis and
slos here's an example of how you can
use a latency metric written by
prometheus
to create a distribution cut sli and set
an slo target for it
a distribution cut allows you to capture
the percentage of values that fall
within a specified threshold
as defined by range this slo expects
that 98
of responses complete within 500
milliseconds over a rolling 28 day
period
prometheus is a popular open source
monitoring framework and it's well
suited for monitoring applications
running in gke
but what if you don't want to maintain
that additional infrastructure
in that case you can use open sensors to
write metrics directly
using the cloud monitoring exporter open
census is a single distribution of
libraries that collect metrics and
distributed traces from your services
let's have a look at how to instrument
your service configure the cloud
monitoring exporter
and use open systems metrics to define
slides and slos
again we'll link to the full code
samples in the show notes but let's take
a quick look at instrumenting an
application written in node.js
to emit counter and histogram metrics
start by configuring the cloud
monitoring exporter this will send the
metrics you capture directly to cloud
monitoring
where you'll then use them to create
slis and define slos
next define a measure for each metric
measures describe how the data points
themselves will be recorded create a
view for each measure
views are basically the time skills
you'll be adding data points to
they also include information about how
that data will be aggregated
for our latency histogram you need to
specify your bucket boundaries
it's important to at least make sure
that you have buckets that capture
requests that are going to fall within
and outside of your slo however you'll
likely want more than just those to
allow you to for example measure p99
latency
finally record values using the record
method unlike prometheus this is the
same for counters and histograms and
open senses
you won't need to configure any scraping
the exporter will write the values
directly to cloud monitoring
you can then use them to define slos
like this here's an example of a
distribution cut sli
using the response latency metric
written by open census
with an slo of 98 of responses being
completed in under 1 000 milliseconds
thanks for joining me today in this
episode we looked at how to instrument
your code to write custom metrics of
open census at prometheus
use them to define service level
indicators and set service level
objectives
against those you're now ready to start
defining slis by using these open source
libraries
in your own services in our next episode
we'll look at alerting on our slos with
air budget burn rates
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud
see you soon
you